البدايه من اخر تطورات الوضع الميداني
والتوتر الامني على الحدود بين لبنان
واسرائيل الذي لا يزال متواصلا لينذر
بالمزيد من التصعيد عشرات الصواريخ اطلقت
من الاراضي اللبنانيه باتجاه اسرائيل عدد
الصواريخ وصلت الى 34 صاروخا اسقط الجيش
الاسرائيلي خمسه وعشرين منها عبر منظومه
القبه الحديديه فيما سقطت تسعه صواريخ
بمناطق عده تسببت باصابه اسرائيليين اثنين
ردا على ذلك قصفت اسرائيل اطراف بلدتي
لقليل والمعليه في قضاء صور جنوبي لبنان
بالمدفعيه الثقيله وفق الوكاله الوطنيه
للاعلام وهي المنطقه التي اطلقت منها
صواريخ الكاتيوشا كما لفتت هيئه البث
الاسرائيليه الى اغلاق المعابر من حيفا
حتى الحدود مع لبنان واغلاق المجال الجوي
شمال اسرائيل وفي وقت نفت ميليشيا حزب
الله علاقتها باطلاق الصواريخ اشارت
التقييمات الاسرائيليه الامنيه الى وقوف
فصائل فلسطينيه خلف الامر مشدده على ان
اطلاق هكذا هجمات من الاراضي اللبنانيه لن
يتم الا بعلم ميليشيا حزب الله
[موسيقى]
يا جماعه بيطلع الصواريخ من عنا شايفين
شايفين من وين
[موسيقى]
لكم من وين عم يطلعوا الصواريخ